Twitter at noontime Twitter app
school-time tweet about it too so fine
when you put Twitter on a bagel you can
eat Twitter anytime that's right I want
talk to you about me and I was up to you
about Twitter and I want to talk to me
about Twitter too because I'm confused
the idea of Twitter there's funny
there's a la ha ha ha ha coming through
the window is that better now my tripod
is stuck on something videos are hard I
used to be so good at this I used to be
so good at this at now I don't know what
I'm doing anymore
the idea of Twitter is basically to
write down exactly what you're doing at
every moment possible except that you
should selectively only type about the
coolest things that you are doing so if
you happen to be hanging out with
somebody really famous who also thinks
that you're really cool and you guys are
having a really good time yucking it up
you should definitely take out your PDA
and tell everyone about that like I
don't think anyone ever tweets their
poops I could tweet my poops I think my
doctor actually suggested that I tweet
my poops
I'm so old note to people who are
confused Hank green has a dysfunctional
column davina Twitter eco geek password
here's a funny thing about me when I'm
telling my password I don't actually
think the name of my password in my head
I used to but one day I realized that
maybe if there was a mind-reader around
he could read my mind while I was typing
so now I type my password and I think
the word password think it's best to
play it safe my doctor says I should
probably tweet my poops and now it's on
Twitter and now everybody that follows
me knows that that my friends is a
killer application of web 2.0 oh my god
how lame the light is back come with me
away from the light
the point of who doesn't seem to be to
let anyone know actually how you're
doing the point of Twitter seems to be
to define yourself to take this thing
that you are this created mechanism that
that the Internet allows you to be with
Facebook and LinkedIn in my space and
your own personal blogs and your Twitter
stream and your Flickr feed
and your YouTube channel on obviously
this is not something that I can
complain about because it's exactly what
Brotherhood 2.0 has largely been about
and what nerdfighting is about that
doesn't mean that it's not really really
really really really really really
really really confusing and peculiar you
know what we are now is that how we
define ourselves and even stranger and
even more puzzling and disturbing is the
fact that those people that you're
connecting with out on Twitter those
people are a new kind of relationship I
imagine that it's very much like the
relationship that I have with
nerdfighters which is not necessarily a
bad relationship but it's a relationship
that hasn't really been defined they're
not fans and they're our friends there's
something in between
there's definitely nerdfighters that I
think are my friends now and I imagine
that I feel the exact same way if I
interacted with all of my followers on
Twitter it obviously serves a purpose it
serves a purpose for the Twitter er the
vlogger or the bloggers you get this
interaction with people who value your
humor and your perspectives and your
ideas and there really is nothing more
important than having people value your
ideas in this society I mean once it
absorb us that people aren't going to
admire you for your hot stud manliness
then people valuing you for your ideas
that's sort of the next best thing and
so I kind of decided that I would try
Twitter but I think I'm going into with
a little bit more knowledge of what the
heck this thing is about it's about
getting that currency that's not money
which is a hard thing to come by I hope
that I provide that currency for some
people too so I guess kind of what I'm
trying to say is thanks for giving me
that and if you want to follow me on
Twitter I think I'm gonna be on there
the slaughterhouse-five boring book club
is complete go to nerdfighters calm
right now all the submissions are in the
forum try and figure out which ones are
your favorites and put them in the new
forum post which I've just posted the
Nuba living book club book is going
postal by terry pratchett and that's all
for now bye
today's question of the day is what is
the weirdest thing you would do for a
dollar